and I'm Alessandra Thought I'm a
pharmacist and I work in a
valente parapharmacy in Perugia the
biggest challenge was having to adapt to the
use of
protective devices therefore the daily use
of masks gloves having to learn to
create a distance between me and the customer
and unfortunately having to reduce the time to be
able to dedicate to him my message is
to stay at home even if
I understand that it is very tiring but
unfortunately today it seems to be the only
weapon we have available to
contain the damage of the pandemic
I hope to be able to return  soon
my life as before so go back to
playing sports and all the activities that I
like to do people can help me
simply by respecting the rules and
having respect for others
together with the strongest all united against
the coronavirus